foreign
Peter is with us in Eugene Oregon hi
Peter how are you
hi Dave I'm doing well I'm looking for
some advice on handling the financial
aspects of the panic that's starting and
it's going to continue around AI
artificial intelligence
where is the panic
well uh
first of all they're looking at it as an
existential threat I understand all the
all the philosophical panic but you're
talking about a financial panic I missed
any Financial Panic yes
um I've worked in uh the AI field for
over 40 years and we're turning a lot of
things over to AI including
I'm aware of that where is the financial
Panic actually occurring
it's on Horizon and we're going to see
bank accounts and mortgage paperwork
that's moved around and gets lost and
I'm wondering how to protect ourselves
uh during this transition over the more
Ai and those kinds of errors can come up
and so okay so there's not any let me
stop a second I just want to make sure
I'm real clear oh yes I don't disagree
with you that AI is a big freaking deal
I'm yeah but but and that there's going
to be a lot of things that we don't even
know are going to happen are going to
happen as a result good and bad by the
way
um there's a lot of reason to be
concerned and a lot of reason to be
thrilled with the potential of AI what
I'm trying to point out is is that there
hasn't been any Financial Panic happen
yet
Yes except in people's minds
but
are there things that I can do
where I can what sort of documentation
what do I need to get together
all right for to protect yourself for
what in particular
uh a couple of things uh well they're
all associated with assets like
mortgages
and paperwork that's at the bank uh it's
not beyond the scope that of what I have
in the bank could be transferred over to
someone else who has a name close to
mine who lives in Timbuktu right uh so
do you keep do you keep banking records
other than digital
um
I keep some I think you keep to go
digital and I'm thinking well should I
go back to asking them to send me paper
copies of everything or just hit print
yeah uh is it is that I mean if you want
to if you want to put a discipline in
place for a period of time because
you're concerned about that if you hit
print that's fine
um I I do not
um
okay
unless the entire civilization as we
know it is collapsed by AI which I'm not
willing to go with that scenario but
unless that occurs the mass transfer of
banking assets to the wrong people is
not going to happen
now it can is there going to be some of
that oh absolutely there is some of that
today you have eight dollar an hour
people coding some of this crap and it
gets in the wrong account now escrow
accounts I bet you I bet you 40 percent
of them are out of balance they can't
even seem to divide their insurance and
taxes by 12 and properly charge it into
the mortgage payment so I mean so we've
always had a level of error the question
is is do the institutions is the is the
level of error so massive that it's
uncorrectable
if it is I don't think there is a
protection for that if it's minor and
you're the one or the one of the five
thousand customers out of five hundred
thousand that had a problem and you've
got to prove it to get your stuff put
back then yeah you probably do want to
protect yourself against that but you
probably ought to be doing that anyway
yeah AI is using data that has it has
been given and so unless your bank
records got hacked and fed into the AI
systems this it feels a little on
verging on paranoia versus the reality I
think the hackers could use AI
to actually actually clean clean out
some accounts to his point I would go
with him on that I don't think that's
paranoia I mean I think the hackers are
like you're going to see hackers use AI
in a way that we haven't even dreamed up
I mean these buttholes can steal stuff
that's not theirs regularly as it is
this is just going to help them so AI is
going to be uh it's a more efficient way
to do fraud yeah that's what it amounts
to but that doesn't mean that the bank
is going to not be responsible for your
ten thousand dollars that was in your
account before some AI aided hacker
cleans your account out it just becomes
one more way fraud could exactly more
it's more efficient for everyone uh to
you know to do content to create fraud
to violate copyrights or trademarks or
steal images so you know if you want to
be crooked it's a more efficient way to
be crooked that's the downside of this
technology it's uh highly Innovative and
highly efficient oh my God it's amazing
but also it's got such a powerful thing
for good and uh it kind of feels like
when the internet was on the horizon we
all went this is scary but also amazing
I think we're just gonna all adapt yeah
but but I think
um to go a hundred percent dark on it
and predict the end of time because of
it I'm as an exit existential threat now
because I still think humans have this
weird idea that we want to be in control
of crap we're not going to let the
robots take over I just don't think I
mean I don't think we're going to need
Will Smith on this I think we're going
to be all right and so uh because we
just we you know people thinking people
are going wow powerful tool scary thing
but wow the vehicle versus the horse and
buggy powerful tool scary thing you can
run over the neighbor's dog hard to do
that with a horse you know I mean it's
uh you know but it but it's a good
reminder to actually make sure you have
good passwords and it's not just
password on those old bank accounts keep
your dog out of the street and keep your
dog out of the street but the uh um
but the two life you know I mean it's
two life hacks but no he's he's right
that
um there's some scary things what I
don't want to do and what I was trying
to push in there is
uh we don't want to add to the idea that
there's already some kind of like stocks
are have lost value in anticipation of
what AI is going to do let me give you
an example of that okay
Y2K
anybody remember that old people young
people Kool-Aid drinkers are you out
there why 2K yes yes
I have a friend who wrote a book about
the end of the world on why 2K made
millions of dollars doing it big best
seller
huge best seller he's written several
bestsellers since then none of them were
like I was wrong about Y2K but anyway
but yeah and uh
did I mean but did stocks go down they
went down what happened in January when
the fireworks went off did the grid shut
down did the world shut down no nope
what happened
nothing oh wait a minute stocks went
right up through the roof January that
year was one of the best years ever look
up January 2000. you'll love it